bella questa di mai che scherzavo spero
che il video di oggi mi piace ragazzi
perché sono di nuovo con il gruppo con
sede a bari youtube italia top the world
godetevi il video ragazzi e scegliamo a
fine paga clooney
la cosa difficilissima secondo me ma
c'era tenta l'impossibile e era appena
un attimo che succede pregare a fare un
pò too much aver sbagliato io pregavo
tutto bagnato e raga non aveva
possibilità di voto fa piacere
e vero ragazza cosa è veramente un
casino perché si corre a una velocità
pazzesca non si capisce una sega
secondo perché comunque adesso ci fosse
ore ad ogni 10 secondi e pochissimo c'è
chi è impostore può fare quello che
vuole praticamente sto gioco quello che
vuole il problema è che la corsa è
veramente forse è nata quindi
teoricamente ok non sta facendo la tasca
come faccio a capire chi e cosa succede
scusate ragazzi ma ma io ho trovato
matteo ne ucciso matteo al fianco in
atto
bravo no non sono io
emergency meeting non si può fare non si
può fare le valige si vi dico che
organistico a via da mark piena marsico
step dato io quando e tasca abbiamo a me
ma c'è un bottone tasche comunque c'è un
botto molto perché siamo abbastanza
vedere di teoricamente 89 88 92 quando
li abbiamo
ma cosa ma cosa giocherebbero ma non è
possibile allora vediamoli inseguire in
atto e poteva andare di qua prova a fare
un po di roba e vedere se funziona
vado in security prendo un po di tempo
all'inizio il reattore ok mi sono messo
reattore se stiamo tutti quanti vicino
che non solo aspettare cooldown e poi di
quella [ __ ] con successo è successo ma
non l'avrai noti e no io sto facendo
ma non solo proseguimento come facciamo
lo avevamo vinto raga se cesca non
usciva impostor a teramo vince usciva
cercano nè impostore avevamo vinto
perché poi tutti avrebbero votato mark
no ragazzi non ci voglio credere
che sfiga che non ci sono le impostori
dichiarati porca vacca la gara vinta e
ravin tissima perché tutti avrebbero
portato mark dopo fa cagare che sfiga
che sfiga finale ray o fatto finta di
fare questo perfetto dei suoi membri
quadri sono arrivati secondi siamo su
dovunque sta roba ha fatto bene a farlo
partire alle 7 o lo fanno o faccio
vedere agency
secondo me bisognava monroe partire
prima sto coso ok ma i 498 se qualcuno
dice vamos ucciderlo 6 5 4 3 2 1 6
sì sì no no ora che avete rovinato il
game però a fare chiamate io ve l'avevo
detto
al minuto ogni volta per farla kg questa
ma l'avete rovinata proprio porca [ __ ]
meriti di gente come scelta per non far
vedere domenica ma mica stamo col
turbante cacchio certo come no
[Musica]
bellissimo bisogna dire solo una parola
quindi nel report tu devi dire solo una
cosa non posso dire due parole non posso
dire bisogna dire solo una cosa a testa
e in base a questo dobbiamo trovare il
bosone che comunque è molto
avvantaggiato perché puoi dire solo una
cosa una mi fa strano che puoi dire solo
una cosa sola è veramente stranissima
come roba non ho mai fatta solo un gas
sta cosa qua quindi con una sola parola
devo essere abbastanza convincente
ok de martino che parla march di e marc
marquez nino storage ma era solo una
parola se lo storage storia invece
l'abbiamo sentita partiamo le storie
partiamo dopo l'uno viene 2 cesca cosa
deve essere comunque in persona italy
impostori visibili ragazzi io ho detto
che cerca perché me la mela contava
veramente sbagliata mela contava
veramente sbagliato a cerchio vi giuro
mi raccontava sbagliatissima per i non è
perché ha cambiato la posizione di live
quindi non può essere lei march secondo
me non è se com'era cesca però ci sono
sono altri pastore ancora pivot non è in
atto ma il nostro ragazzo
ditemi quello che volete ma secondo me
il nostro dell'impostore march mi sta
seguendo non ci voglio credere
non ci voglio credere
vai via mike
la professionista
no no no no no no
benedetto marci guardate perché si è
sbattuto e fatto fini
[Musica]
ed eccoci qua come vito di oggi spero vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi lasciato momento
questo lasciate mi piace sempre piaciuto
il video e noi come sempre dopo che vi
siete iscritti a canale ci vediamo al
prossimo vito bella ragazzi
[Musica]